we really as engineers need to take
responsibility to work on the things
that will make the world a better place
I find it deeply ironic that a country
that was largely populated by people who
gave up everything they had to try some
new thing to find a better life that 100
200 300 years later were suddenly
becoming timid people are understanding
that robot systems don't exist in a
vacuum
that our robots regardless of what they
do are going to have to interact with
humans at the end of the day we need to
be multidisciplinary we need to pull in
lawyers and policy makers and people
from social sciences it's not just about
technology is just doing that in their
individual labs it's not just about
policy makers making decisions in a
vacuum we need to actually get these two
groups of people working together
talking to each other in the same